well gentlemen this is a challenge we're
calling perfect timing if you do ladder
pattern Damascus you get three hours for
round one of the competition keep your
eyes on your clock because that time
starts now my name is Marcus wise I'm 28
years old and I'm an American farriers
Association certified journeyman farrier
I'm expecting my first daughter soon and
if I win this ten thousand dollars I
think I'm gonna put it in a bank account
for her I'm not used to making blades
this long I'm used to making a five inch
blade for castrating cattle and the cow
pins we call them nut cutters
now that I got my weld set I'm gonna go
ahead and start drawing it out and start
cutting my ladder pattern in
now that I've got the profile forged out
I want to get the holes drilled in my
handle before I Harden it
bingo
got my holes drilled now I just need to
go to the grinder and get the profile
done
looking down on my blade right now I'm
worried that my pattern doesn't have
enough of a ladder pattern to get me
through to the next round but I can't do
anything about it
my name is Jesse Overton I'm 28 and I am
from Medford Oregon
as in the Marine Corps for four years
being in the Marine Corps one of the
biggest things that we pride ourselves
on is being able to adapt and being
flexible and I think that all those
things really are going to make me
prepared for this competition I go with
just a basic Camp utility knife so I'm
thinking it's going to have enough
forward weight on it to be a good
Chopper but it's also going to have that
slight curve up towards the tip for the
slicing test
my forged welds are set so I'm going to
stretch that Billet out get ready to cut
it and stack it and weld that back
together to get 60 layers so that
pattern really pops out of that Billet
I'm grinding my ladder pattern in right
now and I realize I've spent way too
much time on this Billet
I need to press out all these grind
lines in order to get a blade to turn in
boom all right Jesse is quenched that's
a great color
[Music]
straight huge weight lifted off my
shoulders
I like it that Jesse's leaving that
blade in there for a while as opposed to
just dipping it and spraying it which we
usually get
I pull out of the edge and I'm feeling
really good I'm glad now that I took the
time in the beginning of the round to
really get that layer count high because
I'm seeing a really nice pattern in the
steel my name is Jordan Kepler I'm from
San Inez California I am a full-time
graphic designer and a part-time
bladesmith I do a lot of camping out of
my truck out there having one knife that
you can chop wood make your campfire
prep dinner and all that stuff is pretty
important
I really want something that is a good
Chopper because we're going to be
cutting into these metal clocks so I go
with a recurve buoy knife for a full
tank I've done a few ladder patterns
before so I'm comfortable with it I
think this weld has taken really nicely
so I'm going to cut in the ladder
pattern I think I got a deep enough
pattern into the Billet so I want to go
draw this back out so at this point I
need to heat treat
Jordan Quinn
it's perfectly straight
wow that's a good looking Place
beautiful
so I'm gonna get this blade ground down
on the Pebbles as far as I possibly can
and then I want to make sure that I at
least have three to five minutes to
start an acid Edge just to make sure
that I can see that ladder pattern
Damascus five four three two one this
round is over good job guys
gentlemen congratulations the three of
you are moving forward into round two of
our competition are you guys going to
fix any issues you have with your blades
and add handles to them turn them into
fully functioning weapons keep in mind
after this round the judges are going to
test your blades for strength and
durability in a metal clock chop and for
sharpness in a rubber hose slice
all right gentlemen good luck that time
starts now all right find a piece of
brass and decide to use this for my
garden
Marcus is going for a standard Tang
setup putting that whole Tang in a big
spot all the way through there that's
creating a lot of work a u-guard would
have saved him a lot of time
I need some time to clean up what the
judges asked me to that really sucks
I realize I've actually drilled this
hole too big and it could slide off the
front of this blade so what I'm gonna
have to do is just use the epoxy and
pray that it holds
oh guys Marcus just cracked it too
I can't believe that this happened
I gotta start over with a new handle
material we don't have time to cry about
it just got to get a new piece cut and
get this handle back on there this
handle is not going to be great but I
think it'll stay on and at least allow
it to be tested
time that I have left I know that a
sharp strong Edge is going to be more
important than a comfortable handle I
don't want to mess around with making a
guard I've already got too much to see
on the blade I don't want to add more to
it I'm hogging off material and I
realize I don't have enough time in this
round to sit there and just keep doing
that so I think Fuller on both sides the
Fuller on the Blade's a great idea
that's the fastest way to drop weight
off that blade after I get those Fullers
in it's time to epoxy this thing up so
I'm rushing through this handle and
before I Know It This grinder is taking
out way too much handle material towards
the inside of the Tang so now I've got
metal exposed and that's really
dangerous for a user I gotta get this
Tang back underneath the scales where it
should be
I hope I got it sharp enough we'll see
when it comes to the rubber tube slice
I constructed my knife so that it has a
full Tang in it now that I have my pins
and wood handle scales set I want to
epoxy everything together and then I
pound in on the pins already that are in
there to transfer some divots into the
wood that I could then go drill out
it goes right on
so I think I have the handle where I
need it to be I'm just going to start
getting this thing sharp three two one
round two this competition is over
this is the strength test the clock chop
now I'll be taking your weapons and
chopping into our clock faces here
pretty much as hard as I can and we'll
see what happens Jordan you're up first
you're ready for this yes sir okay
okay
[Music]
foreign
off for a four hour blade I'm really
impressed you took
some really minor
rolls on this blade but I wouldn't run
my finger down this Edge I wind up
bleeding all in all in a strength test
you held up beautifully good job thank
you all right Jesse your turn you ready
for this I guess you could say it's time
to test this blade
[Applause]
good job dude
all right Jesse I'm gonna start with
your handle here
contouring on this for my hand is pretty
much spot on well done there as far as
your blade goes this might be the only
the third time we've seen in competition
where a Smith used Fullers to lighten a
blade without being prompted to do it so
really good idea
still heavy it's got a fat Edge but hey
man it held up beautifully good job
all right Marcus you ready it's nothing
natural about this
oh
boy
[Music]
oh nice and didn't snap
all right Marcus
the big issue I have with your blade is
this handle it tapers to the back to the
point where retention on this is just
not there as far as your blade goes this
section that's been hit has taken
some pretty serious roles but the
Blade's still in one piece so good job
thank you
all right you guys survived the brutal
strength test now only time will tell if
your blades will survive this sharpness
test
the rubber tube slice
I'm trying to cut through these rubber
tubes in one clean slice
joining up first you ready yes sir let's
do this
nice nice
all right join us talk about your bleed
here first up I really like the designs
you have in its profile The Edge is
sharp and there were no issues cutting
through these rubber holes at all
overall sir you will cut
all right Jesse your turn you ready
let's do it let's do this
all right Jesse let's talk about your
blade here your Edge being a very thick
blade you can tell it's uneven in its
grinds so it barely cut the first tube
didn't cut the rest overall sir your
weapon look up thank you
all right Marcus your turn you ready
swing for the fences let's do it
all right Marcus let's talk about your
blade here despite the fact that you
took some damage there it is sharp now
your handle Construction
I'm not a big fan of it at all
not comfortable to hold on to in the
spot that I do find comfortable actually
has a hot spot in that yes sir but your
weapon you look up awesome
[Music]
all right gentlemen you guys all clearly
made it through the strength test and
our sharpness test but as you know only
two of you guys will be moving forward
into round three of the competition and
the judges have made the decision
The Boy Smith leaving the forge is
Marcus Dave's going to tell you why
Marcus your blade took more damage in
the strength test than any of the other
blades now I did manage to cut those
pipes and we all agreed that your handle
construction over time would really be
difficult to use that's why we're
letting you go
marks you fought extremely hard so
commend you for that but unfortunately
I'm gonna have to ask you please step
off the floor
hey guys it's honor and privilege well
done Bud good job good luck guys
well damn
obviously I knew that the handle wasn't
going to be very comfortable so I can
completely understand why they made the
decision that they did
even though I didn't win it was an
opportunity of a lifetime and I'm
tickled pink that I came